jonathan is with us in olympia
washington
hi jonathan how are you i'm doing good
dave about yourself
better than i deserve what's up hi hey i
just uh had a question for you we are my
wife and i are on baby step two
and things have been going pretty good
um over the last year we paid off about
thirty thousand dollars in debt way to
go um
thank you yeah the only problem i'm
having i have the
the ramsey plus every dollar app going
on and everything
but the problem we have is the
miscellaneous category
things that we don't buy every month um
trying to keep it within the parameters
that i've set
is it seems like it's almost impossible
i know it's not but it's just it's hard
to
plan for what might come up like for
instance you know we just got a
little twenty thirty dollar things you
know death by a thousand cups
hey um like we just got a puppy and we
they get a baby gate for it
you know and uh to keep it from going
all over the house with
20 30 or we ship off a
package through a family member and pay
the postage for that you know another 15
20
how what's the best way to really keep
that in check
and where we're not you know arguing
over it
all the time for these things that we
don't really know what's going to come
up
how much are you putting in there um i
have a set of 100
a month okay and and so the discussion
is how long you've been doing this
how many months um since
last may so almost a year okay so out of
a year
how many times has this been a problem
every month
pretty much yeah okay
is it the sense that one of you thinks
the other one is overspending
or have you just simply underfunded this
account
that's kind of what i'm wondering if
maybe i've underfunded i mean i try to
be really
strict and i have you know i have
adjusted the budget every month like you
say
it can change um do you have good
records
do you have good records on uh if we
want to get real nerdy on where the
money went
that came out of that account um
probably not that great i mean it's from
here
there's two options there's two options
one is lighten it up a little bit just
make it 150 and let's move on okay
uh okay and there's nothing wrong with
that because you're just recognizing
that you have a miscellaneous need that
is higher than you've been budgeting for
and we need to have reality in the
budget versus mythology
the second thing you could do is you
could find a trend that
a certain you need a new category that
splices off
and you need to put 50 in that new
category that keeps showing
up in this miscellaneous over and over
and i don't know what that new category
is
it could be puppy i don't know what it
is but and you know it could be that
that category is what's draining you dry